Here's an example of Snort rule.
Typically the root user account is
used only for specific privileged
operations such as picking out file
systems and setting up subnetworks.
It is quite uncommon to send
email using the root account.
And such an event should
trigger an alert.
Here's an example of how
Snort can capture this event.
It looks for traffic to the SMTP
port on any host in the /24 network,
and checks if the content
of the email contains,
mail from: root, which indicates
that a root user is sending email.
It then sends an alert with
the following message,
root users attempt to send email.
The content keyword here is one of
the more important features of Snort.
It allows the sys admin to
set rules that search for
specific content in the packet payload
and trigger response based on that data.